[Music]
and somebody need to
gra I can
I got
[Music]
toy
sh
[Music]
[Applause]
hosana
hosana hosan in the
highest
hosana
hosana in the
high
hosana
hosana hosana in the
highest
hosana
hosana hosana in the
highest
hosana
hosana hosana in the
highest
hosana
hos hosana in the
high
hosana hosana in the
highest
hosana
hosana hosana in the
highest hos
hosana hosan in the
highest
hosana hosana in the
highest let's sing it together
hosana
hos
hosana in the
highest
hosana
hosan hosan in the
highest hosana in the
high
awesome kiddos you are
dismissed yeah kids are dismissed you
can go to your classes follow the Palm
[Music]
leaves oh my goodness I love getting to
be up here and watch your all do that
because some of you are really into it
and then some of you are like feel real
awkward and it's beautiful all of it
it's all beautiful it's all good um so I
was thinking about Palm
Sunday and like what a really really
like happy exciting
celebratory day this is for us right but
wow they are so
excited they are so excited to be pal
Palm palming um but I was thinking about
about this day and uh like the three of
us up here we were talking about how how
heavy it actually has felt for us in our
lives lately um like yesterday I
attended a funeral of of a boy on my
son's football team he was nine and you
know I found it really hard to shout
hosan today you know it just felt really
heavy and I know a lot of a lot of you
are going through some similar things
and so what we were talking about is not
wanting to fake our hosas like not
wanting to fake excitement like that's
not the kind of church we are you know
we're not going to pretend that things
aren't hard but the beauty about the
word Hosanna is you know it means
literally you know save us you know so
they'd be they'd be you know exclaiming
this like oh salvation is here so as
Jesus is writing in Salvation is here
but that may not be how you're feeling
today so depending on the context of
your life you might be saying yes
salvation is here and or you might be
saying save me I need help and so as
that has helped me today in in not I'm
more of in a I need saving today I need
help I'm I'm asking for saving um so
whatever context or whatever place that
you're in you know singing hosana can be
can doesn't have to be like a fake
excitement it can be an honest like I
need saving I need help I'm feeling low
and so as we sing this next very happy
hosana song you know just realize that
we we hear are naming like it is okay to
not be excited if you're not feeling
that and you can still sing Hosanna
honestly and
authentically
[Music]
yeah
Praises
Rising eyes are are turning to
you we turn to
you hope is
stiring hearts are yearning for
you we long for
you cuz when we see you we find strength
to face the
day in your presence all our fears are
washed away are washed
away
hosana
hosana you are the God who saves us
worthy of all all our
Praises
hosana come have your way Among Us
welcome you here Lord
Jesus the sound of Hearts we
turning to
you we turn to
you in your
kingom
broken lies are made
new you make us
new cuz when we see you we strength to
face the
day in your presence all our fears are
washed
away washed
away
hosana you are the God who saves us
worthy of all our praise
prises
hosana
hos come have your way among us we
welcome you here Lord Jesus sing hosan
hosana
H you are The God Who saves us worthy of
all our
Praises
hos
hosana come have your way among us we
welcome you here Lord
[Music]
Jesus
it says in Psalms
145 I will exalt you my God the
king I will praise your name Forever and
Ever every day I will praise you and
extol your name forever and ever great
is the Lord and most worthy of Praise
God's greatness no one can
fathom one generation commends your
Works to another they tell of your
Mighty acts they speak of the Glorious
Splendor of your majesty and I will
meditate on your wonderful
Works they tell you of the power of your
awesome works and I will Proclaim your
great Deeds they celebrate your abundant
goodness and joyfully Sing of Your
righteousness the Lord is gracious and
compassionate slow to anger and rich in
love
[Music]
see you your life you give
life you are
love you bring light to the
darkness you give
hope you restore
every heart that is
[Music]
broken and great are you
Lord It's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise pour out
a praise it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise to you
[Music]
only you give
life you are
love you bring light to the
darkness you give
hope you
restore every heart
that is
broken and great are you
Lord It's your breath it's your
breath in our
lung so we pour out our praise pour out
our praise it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise to you
only it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise pour out
our praise it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise to you
[Music]
only
sing all the Earth and all the Earth
Will shout your praise our hearts will
cry these bones will sing and
great are you
[Laughter]
Lord and all the Earth Earth Will shout
your praise our hearts will cry these
bones will sing
great are you
Lord all the Earth Will shout your
praise our hearts will cry these bones
will sing
great are you you
Lord all the Earth Will shout your
praise our hearts will cry these bones
will sink
great are you
Lord It's your
bread in our
lungs so we pour out our praise pour out
our praise it's your
bread in our
lungs so we pour out our praise to you
only it's your
praise in
our so we pour out our praise pour out
our praise it's your
pra in our
lung so we pour out our praise to you
only and great are you
[Music]
Lord and great are you
Lord so
[Music]
great even we don't
see you
are and we don't
believe
it you're
[Music]
great we don't see
see
you sing it's your breath it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise pour out
our praise it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise to you
only it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise pour out
our praise it's your
breath in our
lungs so we pour out our praise to
[Music]
you yes Jesus we are proclaiming your
greatness even even in times God where
we
feel that we may question the greatness
when we're full of doubt and
unbelief help our
[Music]
unbelief God when things are going
really
good help us to trust that it's just
going good that it's not the Calm before
the
[Music]
storm Lord when we shout hosana we both
shout save us
and we are grateful for the saving
that's already
happened move in our hearts
God move in our
hearts that we may experience you that
we may taste of your
goodness that we may rest in the faith
and trust that we have
we ask this in your name
[Music]
[Laughter]
amen
my old eyes I forgot to get my my little
light
almost
40 this
may some of you are like that's
young and some of you like it's pretty
freaking old it's pretty it's up there
well uh Grace and peace my name is Brett
and um yeah it's really really good to
be with you and especially um I want to
welcome you if this is your first time
um I know it can just it can be a lot
walking through those doors and and
depending on church back grounds and
things you know people have different
experiences um maybe for some of you've
been here a while and it's still kind of
like deep breaths it's going to be okay
it's going to be these people are very
kind you know um and uh there's just
yeah there's sometimes spiritual
religious trauma things of that nature
so um so thank you for for being here
and uh of course that welcome though
extends to everyone um really glad that
you're all here and that as always
includes those join us online too y'all
are not forgotten so uh it's obviously
um PA Sunday think that was clear uh
that was he is so good I was very proud
um I do it's every every year we do that
and uh it is it's always interesting to
see how people re respond to it um but
it's it's a an important kind of day in
the in the Christian calendar because it
it begins um what's known as Holy Week
so uh kicks off Palm Sunday some
Churches celebrate um what's known as
Monday Thursday we don't um do that
service then there's good Friday that's
the day of the Cross uh so we will be
here um and uh 7 o'cl we're going to
join in Saxy first has their canata kind
of musical service so we'll we'll join
in I think I'm doing like a few
scripture readings or something so um so
it'll be mostly a Saxy first service but
you know everyone at the table they
wanted to extend that welcome to us so
so we'll be here and and then of course
Saturday Easter so um it is it's a a
special week so this um this Palm Sunday
though the title of my my message
message is becoming water becoming water
our passage is Mark
11: 1 through 10 which reads as they
approached Jerusalem and came to Beth
Page in Bethany at the Mount of Olives
Jesus sent two of his
disciples saying to them go to the
Village ahead of you and just as you
enter it you will find a cult tied there
which no one has ever ridden untie it
and bring it here if anyone asks you why
are you doing this say the Lord needs it
and we'll send it back here shortly so
apparently some people kind of speculate
like did he like have this Arrangement
beforehand is this like a miracle you
know uh we're not sure uh we don't
really know it is it's an odd little
interaction like so we just you just
want us to steal this go he's like yeah
don't worry it'll be fine um so they
went they found a cult outside in the
street tied at a doorway as they untied
it some people standing there asked what
are you doing untying that cult they
answered as Jesus had told them to and
the people let them go when they brought
the cult to Jesus and threw their cloaks
over it he sat on it many people then
spread their cloaks on the road while
others spread branches they had cut in
the fields you can see where the
tradition of the the palm branches since
that's a very popular tree um there in
the ancient
eist those who went ahead and those who
followed shouted
Hosanna blessed is he who comes in the
name of the Lord Lord blessed is the
coming Kingdom of Our Father David
hosana in the highest
heaven so in their um their book the
last week biblical Scholars Marcus Borg
and John Dominic crosson give this this
kind of wonderful background to um
everything that's happening in this
passage and um and really in Holy Week
in general um what they kind of point
out is that um this
this whole kind of procession Jesus
entering Jerusalem it's coming just
before the Jewish um kind of religious
tradition of Passover so basically the
Jewish people were beginning um their
own kind of Holy Week so to speak and if
you if you know the story so the
Passover this is from the book of Exodus
uh the story you ever seen the movie The
Ten Commandments even if you haven't
like read it in the Bible you're kind of
familiar so it's the story of how the
Jewish people were enslaved for um
hundreds like 400 something years there
in
Egypt and how the Lord kind of LED them
out with as the the biblical writer puts
it a mighty hand and an outstretched arm
it was this um very kind of cataclysmic
uh at some level kind of violent um kind
of bringing out of of these folks so so
every year right that's like a big
enough kind of founding event for people
that they didn't just like have that and
then move on
they remember it so every year the
Jewish people you know have this this
meal the really it's kind of a series of
meals this um kind of remembering of how
the Lord brought them out and of course
it becomes kind of a parable of how the
Lord continues to you know bring them
out bring us out and and so on so what
would happen what what Borg and crosson
point out in their book is what would
happen is people would stream from all
over the world to Jerusalem
for the Passover like to be able to
celebrate it there in the holy city now
the ancient Jewish historian Josephus he
said that uh he was a contemporary of
Jesus he said as many as three million
people would all gather there in
Jerusalem now modern Scholars think
that's an exaggeration partly because
Jerusalem isn't like gigantic you know
it's not U I don't know whatever like
just some huge it's certainly not Los
Angeles you know it's I mean it's really
like a Saxy or something you know what I
mean like it's it's just not a bit you
can imagine though but even if so even
if it's not 3 million even if it's I
don't know you know a half million a
quarter of a million I mean still
hundreds of thousands of people I mean
imagine like here in a little saxi with
our whatever prob 30,000 like if all of
a sudden 250,000 people descended into
saxi you know just like oh my gosh what
is going everywhere you turn it's just
people you know uh so that's that's kind
of the the atmosphere in the city
regardless of exactly how many people
were there it was El electric and so and
because of this the um the
Roman government
would well this was a jumpy time for
them because they of course they had
conquered Jerusalem and the surrounding
region so even though the Jewish people
are living there they're not exactly Ru
ruling themselves so it's this sort of
uncomfortable
situation and so would happen is um each
year pilot would um bring in
a h a large contingent of soldiers from
the west from
cesaria uh who would March into the
city with the
intention of keeping the
peace but how are they going to keep the
peace it's through violence or at the
very least the threat of violence you
have a few thousand soldiers marching I
mean just so IM
imagine uh you
are
there um in the city of Jerusalem just
before the Passover is going to happen
in a few days and suddenly in the
distance you can hear it you can hear
the march of the boom boom boom boom
left right left right swords clattering
uh Shields shining in the sun you hear
The Rolling Thunder of hooves for war
horses and chariots it's the power of
Rome it's the it's the violence of Rome
and it is coming through those West
gates to keep the peace right this is
kind of the way of the world you know
what else can you do but you keep the
peace through violence now I want you to
have this in your mind though that from
the
East a very different procession is
happening can you see it
can you see the contrast in rides
Jesus and and here I mean the the whole
Spirit the whole vibe like this is a
completely different procession right um
but of course it's still like it it's
its own thing it has um even it has its
king here you have kind of pilate uh and
over here you have Jesus but one sort of
writing this War stallion leading a bun
of soldiers Jesus riding in of course uh
famously on a donkey uh one carrying
their weapons the other of course
carries no weapon at all in fact I just
I just sort of imagine Jesus there
riding in on that donkey and I just kind
of Imagine him like opening up his arms
wide like just showing like making
himself vulnerable showing he's not he's
not carrying some dagger he's not there
to intimidate and force and of course it
would be also a picture wouldn't it a
picture of of the Cross to come just a
few days later like it's such it's such
a powerful contrast two different
kingdoms two different cultures two
different two very different ways of
being in the
world and it seems to me that 2 thousand
years
later it's like the church is still
taking this picture
in Pilot from the
West Jesus from the East different
kingdoms different culture two ways of
being it's like we're still taking it in
trying to not so much just understand it
intellectually I mean hopefully even
from what I've named you can kind of get
it but it's like there's getting it
and then there's getting it you know
what I mean and it's like that's where I
think the church we're still getting
it maybe the the way I could um kind of
sum this up to if you if you wonder kind
of what's what does this mean for our
own lives I want to put it like this
that we all begin our life on the path
of
pilate but a whisper in our soul calls
us
beckons us to the path of Christ we all
begin just like
pilot but hopefully at some point we
start to transition to the way of Jesus
I found uh Father Richard roar's
language of the first and second half of
life to be very helpful in this regard
um and don't take half too literally
like at exactly age 40 you transition to
the way of Jesus and everything's
different and you know like well not
exactly um obviously some folks it can
be happen much earlier for some of us
you much later in life but I I like the
language of half
because kind of implies there's a
maturing and a growing into this process
and it also implies that you kind of
need the first half in other words
instead of kind of shaming people like
oh my gosh you're still like on that
path of pilot you know like come on get
over that that's not very mature you
know you're still not you're unspiritual
uh instead it kind of names like well
you know it's a journey for folks you
can get it up here it's just a journey
to have it sink in and it just doesn't
it just doesn't happen
overnight uh and in the kind of way let
me unpack this a little bit so we might
say that that the first half of life
this kind of way of pilot um and pilot
would be a very extreme example of the
first half life it it's sort of it's all
about embrace in our own power and
agency can you see where Pilots a sort
of hyper version of that you know what I
mean it's sort of like very
powerful totally embracing the agency
like sword in hand you know like whoa
okay so it's a very extreme version you
see if you just scale that back it's
sort of what the first half of life is
about like basically you see this so
much in little kids you know that like
you see them developing hey I am a
somebody you know what I mean like it's
just like hey and every kid has to go
through the no face you know and and
actually even as annoying and difficult
and challenging as it is we all know
this is very important like a kid can't
just never learn how to say like no
uh-uh you know like what is it there's a
boundary right there's a sense of I have
a sense of self I have an identity I
have agency it's not just what you say I
get to say too you know and and you can
see where're as you know trying to
parent children that can be very
difficult to work with but it's but it's
very important right can you see where
this first half life it's not as easy as
like oh just skip over that hey just
become selfless just just act more self
like can you really look at a
three-year-old like you really need to
to learn how to let go of your ego you
know it's just
like we wish we could do that you you
can't you can't just can't do that right
there's there's something about that
first half like really doing you've got
to kind of press into that like um yeah
I think little kids they are such a good
extreme version of this where like I
have little kids in my life so they're
they love the thing the look at me look
what I can do and they just want you to
watch you know I mean look at me I can
triple you know look at look at me I my
my niece she's really into the jumping
rope right now she's like look at this
one two three look at me four five ouch
and that's what she say she hits her
shin and then it's one two three ouch
okay watch I can get to 10 one two you
know ouch just over and over and she
loves this right when what's she doing
she's building that sense ofself look at
me look at me I can do things I'm a
powerful person I'm capable I'm a
somebody now you can sense the
insecurity underneath it you know I'm
I'm awesome I'm lovable aren't
I you know you can kind of feel the the
more you need someone to acknowledge
your awesomeness you know you just know
like okay are you okay you need a hug
like it's not you know it's not good
good um but I shouldn't say it's not
good it's just but it's a developmental
thing right you got to go through this
that way um Roar put it he said you
ironically have to have a very strong
ego
structure to let go of your
ego that's the developmental thing you
ironically kind of have to go through
this pilot phase again we'll get into it
hopefully not literally to that level
you know of violence and I'm going to
force you and I'm going to be an
egomaniac you know not that but but at
some level there does have to be this
hey I'm somebody I have agency I have a
sense of self I have an identity yeah I
can do this thing called life I'm
capable you know adulting I can
adult
um but the point of doing that is not to
go
on
forever the first half of life isn't
just all of life though our culture does
in fact think that is so
you know I mean every YouTube video
that's just like your best life now you
too can make millions you know and it's
just like and that's the goal it's just
it's a very first half of like look at
me making millions you know and it's
like there's something strange about
someone in their 90s who's just like you
should see my net worth you know it's
just weird like haven't you I don't know
grown up you know um but you know but
your teens your 20s 30 you know at some
point there you go through that you know
you go through that
but but hopefully you go you grow
through
it and then out of it and eventually
into something
different see in your second half it's
it's not so much about building that
sense of self like that's already done
now what's it
about letting
go Letting Go becoming
vulnerable giving yourself a
way emptying yourself as Philippians 2
talks about I mean I really think
Christian faith in in very profound
levels it is very second half of life
kind of stuff following Jesus like very
second half of life kind of um learning
to trust God right learning even to make
it about others doesn't have to be so
much about you anymore you start to um
serve you start to
give it's not just what you can get but
it's it's it's what you can how you can
Empower other people this was
highlighted um really multiple times for
me in the last few years through um
again my my kiddos my boys they love
occasionally whenever they they hit
certain verses in kids ministry they
like to talk to me about it and I think
for better for worse but it's mostly for
better they feel very they feel like
they can be very honest with me um about
Bible verses and their thoughts and uh
there's one in particular that both of
my boys have mentioned to me at
different stages I guess as they went
through the curriculum and so just two
weeks ago was my youngest son Oak who's
nine and uh he said um
Dad do you know what the dumbest verse
in the Bible
is and I said um which one do you have
in mind buddy and uh and he said he
could tell he was he thought this was a
scandal he said it's that one where
Jesus says if someone slaps you on the
the right cheek just go ahead and turn
to them the other one he said that's the
dumbest verse I've ever
heard and he's kind of threw his hands
he's like that's crazy he said I don't
get
it and I was just reflecting on that the
last few weeks and I thought you know
what he's absolutely right can you see
he doesn't get it but like at a deep
like he doesn't get it he can't get
it not
yet there's got to be some growing some
maturing he's got in
essence like it was um Gandhi the the
Indian revolutionary who who talked
about how if someone's going to in
essence turn the other cheek or act
non-violently from a place of fear he
said it's better that they just go ahead
and be
violent in other words it can't be a
cowardice thing oh God I'm conflict
avoidant oh good thing Jesus said to
turn the other cheek and like can you
see where that's that's not the Jesus
way it's not weak you know what I mean
it's it's profoundly strong that that
takes that's some
journeying to be able to turn to someone
like to not respond to force with Force
that's not something you just do at 12
like that's that's a profound journey
and can you see where pilate embodies
that he's like the ultimate version of
oh you just cry and hit me and see
what's coming you know like it's the
it's the hyper version of that and then
what is
Jesus the opposite it's can you see the
journey can you see the
maturity like that's a such a profound
Journey for Jesus to be able to enter
Jerusalem not prepared to kill to defend
himself but prepared to
die that that's unbelievable
difficult
profound
mature I might put it like this like
Christ we too are invited into the
second half of life to trade the
warhorse of violence for the donkey of
humility the Throne of power for the
cross of gentleness the sword of force
for the word of blessing the ego
inflating path of pilot for the ego
diminishing way of
Christ that's the
invitation that's the journey and and by
the way if that strikes you as just like
that is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard it's okay it's okay but there just
might come a day where it begins to
resonate where you say you know what
I've gone this path of pilot I have gone
about as far as I can go
in that I will make this my way in the
world I will get my way I have power I
have agency I can control I can control
not just me I can control everything and
everyone maybe even the whole world if I
really try you know at some point you
have just gone that road about as far as
you can and at some point you realize
it's not
working it's not working it's as Jesus
said you can gain the whole world
and like find you're like losing your
very
soul and then you start getting
initiated into the spiritual
life into the path of Christ at a deep
level can you see how even churches can
still be very first half of life you
know you too can be rich and blessed and
have it all if only you'll bow the knee
to Christ you know that's like a very
kind of weird first half kind of you
know
while ignoring like yeah what about that
whole thing of you know if you want to
follow me take up your cross and
follow you know it's like oh that's a
different that doesn't preach as well
you know um but it's the
way it's the way you might say that uh
in the second half of life we become
water as opposed to
rock water instead of rock when I think
of rock it's very first half you know it
rock is is it is hard it is strong it is
tough it it forces you know now what is
water water it's it's so it's so
different we're called to become like
water the spiritual life is water Christ
is water what what does water do water
seeking seeking not the highest place
like the mountain tops where does water
go water seeking seeking the lowest
place water
not forcing but water eroding eroding
the hardened
heart water gently gently working never
forcing but ever
inviting conquering only by
forgiveness as William Blake said giving
way making room across bearing not
building across bearing donkey riding
people in water outwardly it may look uh
very hard or I should say it may look
very weak you know but it's not is it
water's not weak like is the ocean weak
is a river weak no water is
impossibly strong Christ is impossibly
strong the way I mean someone who's
entered into that second half of life
and is truly following Christ it there's
a strength there that pilate will never
understand in the same way he did not
understand Jesus at
all but oh it's
impossibly
powerful I love the way Herman hessie
put you can go ahead and put that quote
back up
gentleness is stronger than
severity water is stronger than rock
love is stronger than
Force
and so Christianity and perhaps you know
in a way all religion it's very second
half of life kind of
stuff you know we can practice Christian
faith in the first half of life but just
like my little boy we just don't get it
just weird you know we just don't get it
but at some point at some point we do we
do because we learn that the foolishness
of God is wiser than human wisdom isn't
it
in the weakness of God on the cross
stronger than human
strength in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit amen amen so as
we uh as we come to the table of the
Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine May our uh May our prayer be Lord
Lord rid me of this eag go Lord take me
into the second half of life if that's
your prayer if you want to be there you
know maybe you need to keep working
things out that's fine if so but if you
feel ready Lord take me in the second
half of Life make me like water make me
like
water so the way we'll participate in
communion where we do um take in Christ
uh his his broken body his Bloodshed for
us um the way that we'll do that is
we're just going to kind of go row by
row here so um we'll start here at the
front with Eden and K and we'll just
kind of work we'll just work our way
back um you should know that the red is
wine um the white is grape juice we
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning um if you're here tonight and
you want to participate then you are
welcome to do that um regardless of your
exact you know beliefs or you're like
I'm part of that denomination instead of
this one or you know whatever uh just
know if you something in you wants to
follow Christ something in you wants to
connect with the Risen Jesus then then
you're welcome to to come forward and
participate um and then finally you can
just partake whenever you'd like lots of
folks like to come and kneel here you
can leave your cups um right there um or
you can just return to your seat and and
partake there so this is the table not
of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him
more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you who have failed come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself
meets you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the
[Music]
table
we're going to introduce a new song
today uh I heard I first heard this song
when it came out um a couple weeks
ago and it's very rare but I the first
time I listen to this song it just
immediately brought me to tears because
I not only for me but I just immediately
thought of our community our little
family here and I'm just like I don't
know if I've quite seen a song be just
for our community like I'm like I think
they wrote this for us I'm pretty sure
um
so my I would just relax and take it in
and uh let the Lord speak to you through
it and uh maybe it'll be as meaningful
to you as it has been to
[Music]
me
you are
not what you have
done or what
has been done to
you you are
something like the
ring Sun can you
see that you are
KN you might
have your father's
name or bear the
shame he left
behind but there's new life
flowing through your veins leave some
room to be be
surpris you are
new every
morning you are
new Every
Morning each day
Resurrection waiting to break
[Music]
through
you could
try just for a
start to put the
judge back on the
Shelf all the
loving
kindness in your heart have a little for
yourself you are
new every
morning you are
new Every
Morning each day
Resurrection waiting to break
through you think hope is lost but it's
just
underground the flame might be remember
but the Fire won't go
out all the evidence is pointing to the
truth that daily
Resurrection is still happening in you
you are
new every
morning you are
new every morning
new every
morning you are
new Every
Morning each day
Resurrection waiting to break
through you are
new
[Music]
time
thank
[Music]
you
here
[Music]
and
okay
[Music]
t
that I can send you into your week with
this
blessing you can hold your hands out in
a posture to receive or just open your
heart to these
[Music]
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day so as you go
into your week ahead with it's yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed have a good week and we hope to
see you back here this
Saturday 5:00 p.m. for Easter service
thank you and good
night you are
new every
morning you are new
every
morning each day
Resurrection waiting to break
through you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day
Resurrection waiting to break
[Music]
through